this self-heating lunchbox this led
house plant and this cutting board are
all products shown here at CES 2023 oh
this is cool but quirky Innovative
products like these have faced big
challenges over the past three years you
see it's pretty normal for Hardware
startups who come here to have a tougher
time getting their ideas in the hands of
consumers compared to upstarts focused
on software but this year the economy
and lack of VC funding is tossing in
more hurdles here's why that matters and
what it may mean for the years to come
floor mini is a lot more than just a
plant that lights up it's a real mood
Setter it's reactive it responds to
music can respond to your voice and it's
really pretty to look at so you know
making something that could assemble
easily could fit in someone's house all
of that was a challenge especially the
covid lockdowns was a big challenge the
company originally planned to launch in
2022 but things have been delayed until
later this year consumers price
expectations are you know somebody buys
a TV there's 10 million of those TVs
made a year we'll maybe make 10 000 of
these this year dealing with that Delta
and economies of scale is really
difficult other companies are dealing
with this too for example steambox and
Innovative lunchbox that heats food
using steam yeah you're just pouring the
water into the bottom
pop the lid back on and within 15
minutes I should hopefully have a
freshly steamed meal after a
manufacturing partner in China was
forced to pull out due to strict
covid-19 government restrictions
steambox had to Source new materials for
his product some setbacks through kofit
and had a big impact on our business we
lost our manufacturing partner at some
point because they had to pull back in
in Asia Venture Capital funding is also
drying up dropping more than 50 percent
year-over-year between June and October
of last year CES used to be the place
for Gadget makers to show their most
Innovative Tech hoping for funding or
press attention but it feels a little
different this year pre-pandemic it
wasn't unheard of for CES to attract 200
000 visitors it was a behemoth and the
Jewel in the crown of tech conferences
for innovators but in 2021 much like
everything else it went virtual and
returned last year with just 44 000
people and it's interesting after the
you know the covid break and also the
current economic make situation to see
where companies think they can make
money or convince consumers to spend
their money all of a sudden the pandemic
hits and shuts down the world and I was
like oh no what am I going to do but it
actually was a great thing because it
kind of slowed us down but also brought
awareness to the struggle in
communication other companies are
delaying their products and opting out
of attending CES playing pad for example
considered showing new versions of its
balance board at CES but decided to
shift its plans to 2024. Walking the
Floor at CES this year two things stand
out one there are fewer startups and two
there are fewer eye-catching gadgets
like this novetto N1 speaker from CES
2021 it could wirelessly shoot a beam of
sound directly to your ears also there
was this air-conditioned baseball cap
from 2020. I think after covid Health
Fitness General well-being has become
more important block for example is a
smart cutting board that can display
healthy recipes we're big digital
Fitness people and we realized during
the pandemic that we didn't have an
opportunity to like have folks in our
kitchen anymore and we missed kind of
that communal atmosphere I also saw this
Smartwatch alternative that's powered by
solar panels I'll aim at the Earth our
goal is to make you do the activities
that you never do but you should follow
your health it can have a classic watch
face but also be charged by your
movements while moving away from a lot
of the wild and wacky stuff might make
sense right now I do look forward to
things getting back to the way they used
to be someday